-We don't always
have enough time
to cover all of the recent news.
So here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys,
things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
I heard Jimmy Buffett
sang the national anthem
and dropped the mic!
And I was like, "What?"
Jimmy Buffett
sang the national anthem?
Where?
At a game of beer pong?
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy Buffett
dropped the mic why?
Did he sing
the national anthem well?
'Cause I heard "Margaritaville,"
and I'm guessing that's a no.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you're too old
to drop a mic.
Barack Obama
barely got away with it.
When you -- When Barack Obama
drops a mic, it's cool.
But when you
start dropping things,
your children come around
to check on you.
[ Laughter ]
Then I was watching Fox News,
where they
accidentally announced
that Ruth Bader Ginsburg died,
even though she's still alive.
And I was like, "What?!"
Just kidding.
I wasn't watching Fox News.
[ Laughter ]
But --
I was watching "True Detective."
It was fun.
But I heard about it.
And I was like, "What?!"
You showed this
on national television?
Why?
Were you hoping that she'd
see it and go, "Oh, I'm dead.
Okay. Eh."
[ Laughter ]
Then Beto O'Rourke was like,
"I might run for president."
And everyone was like, "What?!"
Then Elizabeth Warren was like,
"I'm gonna run for president!"
And everyone was like, "What?"
Then Kamala Harris was like...
And I was like...
And then she was like...
And then I was like...
"I'm running for president!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, man.
Everybody was like, "What?"
Then I saw that Beyoncé
shopped at a Target.
And I was like, "What...
could they possibly have
that you need?"
Is it mirrors?
It was probably mirrors.
Then some scuba divers
off the coast of Hawaii
were minding their own business
when a giant great white shark
showed up.
And I was like, "What?!"
Then this fool touched it.
Now, I'm not a shark expert,
snorkeling expert, or swimmer.
I don't like water, animals, or
animals that live in the water.
But I do know that sharks
eat people, idiot!
And you look delicious!
So you may not want
to be swimming up to sharks
like they're your best friend!
I did all that without
mentioning the song "Baby Shark"
lest it get stuck in your head.
Oops, I mentioned it.
Guess it's stuck
in your head now!
[ Laughs ]
Then Gillette aired a commercial
acknowledging toxic masculinity,
saying, "We have to stop saying
'boys will be boys,'"
and I was like, "Yes, we do.
What, what, what, what, what?"
Then some people
didn't like being told
they shouldn't bully and rape.
And I was like, "What?"
Sounds like you've mistaken
toxic masculinity
for your identity.
And the second I said that,
I became an old black lady.
[ Laughter ]
Then a bunch of children from
Covington Catholic High School
went on a trip to D.C. to march
against reproductive rights.
And they thought, "While we're
doing some sexist [bleep]
why don't we also
do some racist [bleep]"
So when --
I mean, whew,
like a mug, though.
When some indigenous people
who were having a separate march
approached them,
the kids mocked them.
And I was all like, "What?"
Didn't you see
the Gillette commercial?
This is what "boys will be boys"
does to people.
Now, these parents
need to sit down
and explain to their children
that this is wrong.
Or -- and this is
an official pitch --
NBC makes a "Scared Straight"
reboot but for racist children.
Now, you send your little
racist children to me.
What am I gonna do to them?
None of your business.
But when you get them back,
they will not be racist!
Then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Listen up.
Then Karen Pence
took a job teaching art
at a Christian school
that doesn't allow LGBT students
or teachers.
And I heard that and was like,
"What...did you expect?
She's married to this guy."
Then I had an idea.
And this is an official pitch.
NBC makes a show called "Scared
of People Who Aren't Straight"
where kids send
their homophobic parents to me.
Now, what am I gonna do to them?
None of your business.
But when you get them back,
they will not be homophobic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then the best thing
in the world happened!
Katelyn Ohashi did
a gymnastics routine
that had everybody like,
"What?!"
Whoo!
It was beautiful!
Her floor exercise
had all the hits --
"Proud Mary," "September,"
"Rhythm Nation."
And then she did something
I will never forget
I saw another human being do.
This!
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Oh!
What?!
Yeah! Yeah!
Am I doing it?
Probably close.
I saw that, picked up
Jimmy Buffett's microphone,
and dropped it again!
This has been "Amber Says What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!